nina and i will more nina need your help
[Music]
what's a believe nation happy weekend
this is a quick video we need your
feedback here's a story Nina loves
plants he's obsessed with plants
everywhere she goes there's plans she
brings when to the office you think
about Tom Springs 10 hot not just 11
explosion to 10 explodes into a hundred
mother hatchet a lot of plants they get
given away to people as gifts all the
time no at the time you just making
things up yeah I do not give gifts of
place I do but not she loves plans one
of the most exciting time you'll ever
see nana is when a new client is pushing
through the ground too much chillin you
got to see this you got to see this I
have one see see see how excited she
just got she's running now she's ready
to go get the plane she's running we
care more about your reactions and
action the plane but Garrett this one
what do you call this plant
mother-in-law's tongue yeah spider plant
yeah so I cut the top and then I put it
in a small pot and it's growing little
one baby plant to see this one
here see the one that's growing in
between these two this one they're so
cute the baby ones are there cute yeah
you see the excitement and then it's
going to be rage on Evan soon see if it
like the scene you see that look you see
that luck to the angry look just taking
about pints think about baby plants okay
so this is my wife this is the life that
I signed up for so we live in toronto
right Canada gets cold in the winter we
got a condo with a balcony so she can
grow her stuff outside and in the winter
you can't grow step outside and so I
thought being a good husband that I am
great yeah the good husband that I am
that I would build an indoor plant
planter planter for her now some of the
plants have done well in their regular
kind of by the window settings so we've
got these ones doing well there by the
window and then see I wanted to avoid
these you know plastic cups by the wind
they will want one so let's come off
they will go into the nena found their
way back into plastic cups so we got
other plants here right those are all
doing well and then we get to this this
is what I built so these are these are
the plants that were outside what do you
got be of kale you've got avocado sage
sage when does baby want that about what
okay so as you can see it's not really
it's not really doing so well I really
doing well and we bought that we bought
the light that's supposed to be a
growing light it's not really working
well and we have Celdran view here
Western view here it's got windows on
both sides getting the light but it's
not enough and the plants are dying so I
said we need a video for this weekend we
need a video and Nina's like make a
video ask you believe nation this is
what we need help with asking the nation
to ha
make this stay alive what do we need to
do to make this grow into amazing kale
bunches of abundance bunch of abundance
I want to kill a bunch of abundance so
for all you guys who are gardeners or
experts and that want to contribute it
would make Nina extremely happy you'll
see lots of smiles and cute faces and a
lot of love and just know in your heart
that evan is benefiting as well
tremendously because I happy Nina my
voice crack a happy Nina lead to a very
happy Evan happy wife happy now I guess
how do I haha and that's important guys
because I will fight all that love into
more videos for you so let us know how
did we save the plants leave in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching if you need to believe or
whatever your one word is what see you
soon